bonsoir Anthony Saint-Léger
mondial au Qatar en pleine controverse
sur les tenues arc-en-ciel et de la
promotion de la diversité au Qatar les
internautes affirment que l'équipe
allemande a dû changer d'avion avant
d'arriver au Mondial en raison d'un logo
prenant la diversité avec effectivement
le message et le suivant avant la
compétition donc un avion contraint
d'atterrir un avion de l'équipe
allemande d'atterrir une contrainte
faite par le
Qatar conséquence une escale à
Oman et la raison un message qui promeut
la diversité sur l'appareil ce message
on le retrouve sur diverses publications
que ce soit twitter facebook que ce soit
en français en anglais comme ici ou même
en arabe et des publications qui ont été
faites le 19 novembre donc la veille de
du coup d'envoi et à chaque fois vous
allez le voir des avec ses publications
de photo à l'appui la première ici où on
voit un avion de la Lufthansa avec ce
slogan la diversité et gagne et puis
cette chaîne humaine formée en guise de
solidarité finalement et des hommes qui
en décembre des hommes qui descendent
aussi de cette seconde photo d'un autre
avion qui vous le voyez cette fois n'a
absolument pas de signe distinctifs de
diversité ni de d'illustrations
particulières cette image serait donc
l'image de l'équipe allemande partant de
Francfort en Allemagne donc celle-ci
serait donc de l'arrivée à Doha au Qatar
laissant penser qu'il y a bien eu un
changement d'appareil entre les deux
destinations alors info ou intox et bien
c'est info et intox parce que ces deux
photos elles sont authentiques et il y a
bien eu un arrêt un changement
d'appareil mais l'arrêt a eu lieu à
Oman et ça n'a pas été imposé par le
Qatar explication l'équipe allemande a
bien quitté Francfort à bord
de la seconde photo et bien la seconde
photo a été prise à l'arrivée des
joueurs allemands sur le tarmac de Doha
au Qatar donc pour la Coupe du Monde
évidemment et vous le voyez l'avion Nani
inscription ni quelconque illustration
et pour cause cet avion c'est celui de
la compagnie régionale
omanair que l'on voit ici on va voir
effectivement les joueurs allemands en
décembre l'Allemagne effectivement
rejoint le
Qatar par le vol de la compagnie
aérienne
Oman r pourquoi parce que aller à Doha
avec Lufthansa comme la liaison
commerciale elle n'existe pas ou en tout
cas est très très peu fréquente aurai
signifié pour la compagnie aérienne un
retour à vide de doigt à Francfort ce
que évidemment elle refusait ce n'est
pas écologique et pour défendre la
diversité gare à ceux qui voudraient
porter les couleurs arc-en-ciel symbole
de la communauté LGBT et oui à l'image
de ces support du Pays de Galles qui
jouait hier les États-Unis qui se sont
vus confisquer leur Bob aux couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel pour entrer dans les
stades Laura McAlister a l'ancienne
footballeuse de la sélection on a relaté
d'ailleurs l'événement elle a été bloqué
pour entrer donc au stade et dans
l'enceinte il en a été de même un
incident similaire avec ce journaliste
américain grent walk qui lui arborait
vous le voyez ce t-shirt aux couleurs
arc-en-ciel et qui a été retenu quelques
instants par les autorités lui aussi
empêché de pénétrer dans dans les stades
il a obtenu toutefois gain de cause
puisque il a pu garder son t-shirt il a
même reçu les excuses d'un d'un
représentant de la FIFA elle en revanche
ne s'est pas vu
représenté pardon c'est à l'ancienne
Première ministre danoise qui était
aujourd'hui assisté au match Danemark
Tunisie et vous le voyez elle arbore
clairement une robe aux couleurs
arc-en-ciel elle qui hier d'ailleurs sur
son compte Instagram publié ce cliché
d'elle avec le fameux brassard One Love
qui a une sorte de symbole contre toute
discrimination y compris LGBT parce que
c'est évidemment dans ce contexte qu'on
a eu lieu tous ces assinances celui
notamment de ce brassard One Love que
cette sélection européenne ont
finalement renoncé apporter face aux
sanctions sportives aux menaces de
sanctions sportives de la FIFA merci
beaucoup Anthony Saint-Léger on va y
revenir à ce mondial dans notre
prochaine édition c'est dans quelques
minutes vous restez avec nous